the austin public library in texas is
now not only offering
spring break sex ed camp for free for
little teenagers to teach them about a
bunch of creepy sex stuff
they're actually they're actually paying
the teenagers to go
to the sex ed camp they're going to pay
you
to go
learn about lots of weird creepy stuff
why
well
what you hear from from the program is
get paid to learn about sex ed
you'll you'll learn about gender
pronouns gender identity when you sign
up you can say are you male female
transgender
maybe you don't identify this program
the austin healthy adolescent program is
a progressive program
that envisions a generation of liberated
youth and young adults who are valued
participants in achieving health equity
so it's like progressive stacking health
equity we're getting a lot of liberal
slogans that don't don't seem to mean
very much right now
this program by the way funded by your
taxpayer dollars funded by the
department of health and human services
this actually clarified my thoughts on
why comprehensive sex education is so
bad
is i don't know i grew up in a pretty
liberal place we had comprehensive sex
ed when i was a kid
wasn't nearly as comprehensive as it is
today
we didn't talk about transgenderism we
didn't talk about
lots of the things that are taught in
these classes but it was still you know
fairly
fairly comprehensive
and there wasn't much of an outcry where
i lived because i grew up in a very
liberal place but i remember at the time
there were huge debates over
comprehensive sex education i thought
what's the big deal why are these
conservatives so upset about it
the reason it's a big deal
is because
it's not just about biology
it's not just about science
no education is just about biology and
science when you're teaching something
like sex
you are inevitably also teaching
something about morality and ethics
and politics
it is it is not possible when you teach
a child what sex is
you must teach them what sex is for
so you can as people used to do say okay
set when mommy and daddy love each other
very much you know when the birds and
the bees
start to get a little frisky is that how
it happens i don't know
what happens is a husband and a wife
will get together and do this thing and
that's how babies are made
and that teaches you that sex is for
procreation it's for men and women
to get together in an institution called
marriage and then and only then should
they have sex and they should do so with
the openness to life to create a new
generation that's not what sex ed is
today
sex said today is that sex is what you
do when you want to feel pleasure
and it doesn't matter if it's a man and
a woman who love each other very much
frankly it doesn't matter if it's a man
a man or a woman a woman who love each
other very much the love that doesn't
that's not a big deal
it can be a man and a woman it can be
two dudes in a goat it can be whatever
kind of arrangement you want that's fine
and you should always use contraception
contraception is really good and really
important and yeah it's true
certain groups like you know the
christians and uh you know other
old-timey religious groups they don't
like contraception but that's okay we're
teaching now is contraception's really
good if you do get pregnant if you do
get that horrible disease called
pregnancy from from sex that's okay you
can have an abortion abortion is good
it's just safe health care there's
nothing wrong with abortion and if you
by the way if you're a man you think
you're a woman that's totally natural
and good and normal and you should
mutilate your body that's what that's
what sex education is it is a moral
education
it's a religious education
it has to be
it that's this is true of all education
but especially when we're talking about
sex something so fundamental to our
human nature
you can't just talk about what the thing
is and divorce that from what the thing
is for
what the thing means what the
significance is
of the act
and this is why they're paying kids to
do it they're paying kids to do it
because they have the state the
political radicals have
a
deep interest in indoctrinating you into
the ruling ideology it appears it
appears
to be working i'm glad you liked that
clip now here's what you got to do
ring that bell subscribe get the
notifications for all the videos that
come out also head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
subscribe to the michael knowles show
that is the
m-i-c-h-a-e-l-space k-n-w-l-e-s
space
s-h-o-w subscribe leave a five star
review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]